I think we're now ready to
start talking about some
general trends in the
periodic table.
And the first one that normally
comes up in a lot of
first-year chemistry classes,
and it even shows up on some
chemistry standardized
tests, is the notion
of ionization energy.
And what this is, is essentially
the energy
required to remove an electron
from the neutral
version of that atom.
So let's see.
Energy to remove an electron.
And just in case you haven't
been exposed to the idea of
what an ion is, I guess this is
a good time to explain it.
And then this will make sense.
So an ion is essentially any
atom or molecule -- and we'll
talk about molecules.
Molecules are just combinations
or groups of
atoms that are all bonded
together in some way.
And we'll talk about bonding
in a few videos from now.
But it's an atom or a molecule
in which the protons don't
equal the electrons.
And if the protons don't equal
the electrons, then you have
some charge.
If you have more protons than
electrons, you have a positive
charge, right?
So let's say if you
have hydrogen.
Let's say you have hydrogen.
Normally it's neutral, right?
It has no charge.
But let's say you were to remove
an electron from it.
So now you have hydrogen
plus an electron.
Hydrogen only has one
electron outside.
So now it just has a proton on
the inside, no electrons on
the outside.
So now it has a plus
one charge.
We could write a minus
one there.
And now, what we've done in
this, I guess we could say,
this procedure or this reaction
is, we've removed
we've ionized hydrogen.
We've removed an electron.
And in this case, this type of
ion that hydrogen is, where
your protons are greater than
your electrons, and this is
just a nice word to know.
This is called a cation.
A cation is an ion with
a positive charge.
Now you just as easily could
have a situation where you
have a, let's say -- I don't
know, let me take an element
-- let's say we start
with chlorine.
Cl, right?
In a stable form in has seven
valence electrons.
Why don't we add an
electron to it.
And now this will actually
be pretty stable.
It will have eight valence
electrons, but it'll have a
negative charge.
So this, right here, this
is a negative ion.
And that's known as an anion.
Anion.
The way I remember it is, in
a lot of words, a means the
opposite or a negation.
Right?
The a prefix.
So a, anion, means
a negative ion.
And then, obviously, cation
is the other.
But ionization energy, it really
should maybe be called
cationization energy, because
it's the energy required to
remove an electron, not remove
or add an electron.
So it's really the energy
required to turn something
into a cation.
So we've already discussed the
periodic table, and we'll get
to this chart in a second.
But just based on what we
already know, which elements
will it be harder to remove an
electron from and which ones
will it be easier?
We already talked about -- let's
start with group one,
just because it is group one.
Group one is right here.
And we'll start especially
with the alkali metals.
We can put hydrogen
aside for now.
But all of these guys we've
talked about a lot.
In order for them to get to
the magic number eight in
their outermost shell, the
easiest way for them to do it
is just to get rid of that one
valence electron they have in
their outermost shell.
Let's say potassium,
right there.
Potassium has one valence
electron in its fourth shell.
If it just got rid of it,
then it has eight
in its third shell.
Then it looks a lot like argon
from an electron configuration
point of view, which
would be nice.
So these guys really want
to give away electrons.
So it requires very little
energy to ionize them or to
cationize them, to take
away their electron.
So this is low ionization
energy.
And I think you see where
this is going.
What about these guys?
What about neon?
How hard is it to remove
an electron from neon.
Well neon is completely
satisfied.
It doesn't want to even deal
with any of this reaction
business and bonding business.
It's like, you know what?
I've achieved happiness
in life.
Don't mess with my electron.
So it really doesn't want to
give away its electrons.
Neon, or krypton, or argon, or
any of these noble gases.
So to remove an electron from
one of these guys requires a
lot of energy.
So this is a high ionization
energy.
So in general, as you go from
left to right across the
periodic table, it goes
from low to high.
And some people memorize this,
but you really don't have to
memorize it.
You just say, look, these guys
have one extra electron that
they're always trying
to get rid of.
These guys have two.
Ideally they'd want to
get rid of, maybe,
both of their electrons.
But the first electron doesn't
want to jump off as much as
the first electron here, because
the first electron
here, you get rid of it, you
immediately get to the super
stable state.
And that trend just becomes
more and more true.
This guy, definitely, under no
circumstances wants to give
away an electron.
This guy is so close to being
like neon that he definitely
doesn't want to go a
step backwards and
look more like oxygen.
So he doesn't want to get
rid of an electron.
So the trend is pretty clear.
Anytime you're confused about
the trend, just look at the
extreme cases.
This guy wants to give
away electrons.
This guy wants to
get electrons.
So if you say, what's the energy
required to take away
an electron?
Well this guy's almost going
to give it to you.
While this guy's going to be
very hard, especially neon, to
take away an electron.
Now what happens
as you go down?
As you go down in this
direction, let's say you go
along a group, right?
We already established that
these alkali metals like to
give away electrons.
But as you go down,
the electron cloud
gets bigger and bigger.
And you could say this 55th
electron -- there's 55
protons, there's also in a
neutral cesium atom, there's
also 55 electrons -- that 55th
electron is a lot further away
from the nucleus of this atom
than the third electron is in
the case of lithium.
So this, the 55th electron, not
only does it want to be
given away, but it has even
a weaker attraction to the
nucleus than the third electron
does in lithium.
So because you're getting larger
and larger as you go
down a group, and the electrons
are getting further
and further away from the
nucleus, this guy wants to
give away his electrons even
more than lithium does.
Right?
So ionization energy decreases
as you go down.
Even though xenon really wants
to keep his electrons, he's a
little bit more willing to give
them away than neon is.
Right?
So in general, the ionization
energy, or the energy required
to ionize an atom, will
increase as you go up.
Right?
And if you ever forget it, don't
memorize these things.
Because that might be useful
for just one test, but then
later in life when you're 42
and someone asks you, hey,
what has a higher ionization
energy, cesium or fluorine?
You might have forgotten it.
But then if you look at a
periodic table, you'd say, you
know, cesium has this one
electron that it's just dying
to give away.
It's super far away
from the nucleus.
That 55th electron just really
wants to leave. While
fluorine, that ninth electron
just needs one more electron.
Well let's say neon.
Neon is super happy.
All the electrons are in the
stable configuration.
They're close to the nucleus.
There's a lot of attraction
with the
protons in the nucleus.
They definitely don't want to
give away their electrons.
So if you talk about the energy
required to remove
them, very low energy
at cesium, very
high energy at helium.
So that's the trend.
And this is just, this trend
we'll see often, this is your
willingness to give electrons.
And this is how much you want to
hog electrons or keep them
to yourself.
And this right here, this is
actually -- I got this off
Wikipedia -- this
is the actual,
measured ionization energies.
And people looked at
patterns like this.
I'm not sure if they actually
looked at the ionization
energy, but they looked at
patterns like this, and this
is actually where they came up
with the periodic table.
Because they said, look, as we
increment up the number of
protons that we have in an atom,
and likewise, the number
of electrons, we see these
repeated patterns, or these
periods, in the elements.
So this is hydrogen.
So hydrogen's ionization
energy is around 13 1/2
electron volts.
Right?
Which is a unit of energy.
It can be converted into
joules, if you like.
But then all of a sudden, helium
is a lot more stable.
It takes almost double the
energy to remove that second
electron from helium because
it's so stable.
But as soon as you do that, as
soon as you go from helium,
this point right here, that
point right here is lithium.
Right?
Lithium is atomic
number of three.
Let me put that in.
This is lithium.
All of a sudden, to remove an
electron from lithium it only
requires five electron volts.
So less than half of what it
required for hydrogen.
Then as you go to the right
of the periodic table, the
ionization energy keeps
increasing.
These little divots
are interesting.
We could talk about that, maybe,
in a future video.
But the ionization energy
increases all the way to neon.
And then you get to neon and
then you add one more-- see,
neon is a noble gas, it's
completely happy -- then you
add one more electron and
you get to sodium.
And you say, oh, now sodium,
it's really easy to take away
that electron.
And the ionization
energy drops.
Not only did it drop,
but here it dropped
slightly below lithium.
So you see this general trend.
So these are the noble
gases right here.
Let me make sure you can see
them all in the video screen.
Helium.
Very hard to remove that
eighth electron.
Neon.
It's very hard, but a little
easier than helium.
And that's because neon is
a little bit bigger.
The electrons are a little bit
further away from the nucleus.
Argon.
Same pattern, but it's
actually interesting.
Argon is actually not that
different than hydrogen.
Krypton.
Same thing.
It's hard to remove
that electron.
But it's actually no harder to
remove the electron on krypton
than on hydrogen.
And xenon.
And you go all the
way out to radon.
And you can see, you know, why
is the distance between these
increasing?
Well if you remember the
periodic table, all of a
sudden when you go after argon,
then you have all of
the d-block elements
that go in.
So after you get to
argon, notice.
This is where you only had
s- and p-block elements.
Now all of a sudden the d-block
elements show up.
So you have more subshells
to fill up.
And now all of a sudden, before
you get to radon,
you're starting to fill
out the f-block, too.
And that's why that distance
is increasing, because you
have to also fill out
the f elements.
But the general trends
that we just
discussed, they apply here.
That as you go to the right
along the periodic table, it
becomes harder and harder to
remove an electron because
everyone wants to get to
the magic number eight.
And it's very hard to remove
them from a noble gas.
But then as you go one more
above that, this guy would
love to give away his electron
and get back to a
configuration like neon.
And then the other trend is,
as you go down a group-- in
this case, these are the
noble gases-- the
ionization energy decreases.
And that's because the overall
radius of the atom increases,
so the valence electrons in
radon are a little bit less
strongly attracted than the
valence electrons in helium.
Anyway, I think that's it
for ionization energy.
I'll continue this
in another video.
We'll talk about metallic
character and
electronegativity.